[Music]
so we're so happy you guys are back I'm
happy we're back too because you know
with everything going on in the world
I just loved having this entertainment
fun for laughing we're having a good
time you forget about what's happening
in the world for like two hours he's a
human and you're a mouse well I didn't
think that would be an issue
I mean how he was married to a seal
we're so excited for the new season
Project Runway what is very exciting
about this year we have models of all
sizes which I believe we should have
done already years and years and years
ago so I'm happy though that now this
season we're starting these girls they
have curves and butts and hips and all
kinds of good stuff
what were the designers reactions
knowing that they would have to design
for women who maybe don't fit the
typical you know model standing
you know some of them a lot of them
actually weren't too happy about it no
but you know this is the real world so
not everyone is you know runway figure
or what the runway figure used to be you
know you have to dress real people and
real people come in different sizes
short tall low voluptuous skinny you
know there's many of us and so a real
designer needs to know how to do that so
get with it long trailer also teased a
lot of drama there's a contestant walks
off the runway with the way that it was
done I do not agree with I came to play
fair there's no fairness what happened
what cuties about that moment I mean you
have to watch and see this I have never
had this happen before you know
especially when I'm like hey guys what's
going on and they don't listen to me
either they just walk away I'm like wait
a minute
I run this show like what is going on
here you guys all a little too
comfortable in my studio well we're in
for an exciting season